with a hilarious deleted post-credits
scene a surprise ending for camilo and
an even darker fate for abuela's husband
the ending of encanto was almost very
different yupikai movie lovers i'm jan
and in this video i'm revealing the
alternate endings for encanto you never
got to see spoilers ahead of course so
take care
during the beautiful melancholy song dos
uruguitas we get the full backstory of
abuela and her husband pedro how they
met fell in love got married had
triplets and then how he tragically died
trying to protect his family and the
town's people from a group of soldiers
however this scene was originally going
to be even more heartbreaking because in
early drafts alma and pedro had to flee
their town before the children were born
and according to encounter co-director
jared bush there was a version where she
had the babies at the river and they
were born the same moment pedro died now
pedro's fate was already pretty dark for
a disney movie but i think that alma
giving birth as their husband died
beside her would have been even more
bleak there is a tiny trace of this idea
in the final movie and the following
line which bush has confirmed does imply
that pedro died on the very day the
triplets were born when my three babies
had just been born urabuelo pedro and i
were forced to flee our home thankfully
they decided not to go with this
alternate ending meaning pedro did at
least get to say goodbye to his three
children before his death
bush also revealed that chispy the
capybara had a funny fully animated
post-credits scene that didn't make it
into the movie in the deleted scene
chispy lifts his leg to relieve himself
on the casita but the magical house
stops the little capybara by tipping a
drain full of water on him giving the
creature a taste of his own medicine
bush said the scene was cut because they
preferred to finish the movie on the
emotion and joy of the family coming
back together the mischievous casita can
also be seen pranking a capybara in this
unused concept art where it tips the
cute creature off a chair
in another alternate storyline mirabelle
had a confrontation with her mother
julieta at the end of the movie rather
than her grandmother as happened in the
final film in this version it was
mirabelle's anger with her mother that
led to the casita's destruction as with
each angry word she uttered it was as if
a blow was being struck to the house
causing it to break apart the idea was
that mirabel and casita shared a mental
connection so her rage would end up
wrecking the family home
in another version of the story the
casita was destroyed by fire burning to
the ground rather than crumbling to
pieces it would have been especially
poignant for a fire to destroy the
magical house given that it owed its
existence to a candle in the aftermath
of the fire the windows and doors
survived to give a sense of the original
layout of the home and a spooky
ghost-like shadow was also going to
appear this was supposed to feel like
there was a ghostly spirit still in the
ruins of the house a shadow that haunted
it perhaps that of abuela's pedro it was
meant to feel scary and threatening
although as the camera drew closer it
would be revealed to actually be the
remaining cracks of the house
a potentially confusing alternate ending
for camilo was considered at one time
where according to jared bush after the
house fell and the magic died camilo
reverted to his true self and no one
recognized him that ending would have
meant that the appearance we saw camilo
used throughout the movie when he wasn't
shape-shifting wasn't actually his real
form it was just another character he
was pretending to be i can see this
ending for camilo could have been
distracting given the number of
questions it would have raised and as
bush explained it was scrapped because
the moment had to be about mirabel
the casita also took on some creepy
ghost-like characteristics in this
unused concept art where the house
revealed there was something wrong by
having all the paintings and pictures go
blank the idea here was that the casita
was sick in a way and was experiencing
the kind of memory loss or brain fog
that people can get sometimes when
they're sick or suffering
another way to represent the magic going
wrong was this scene where the yellow
butterflies would have all gone dark
giving the moment a very spooky and
creepy vibe
and these unused pieces of concept art
show how in another version of the movie
the casita could literally float above
the ground both before it was destroyed
and later again when mirabel restores it
a deleted scene released by disney on
the encanto blu-ray appears to follow up
on the confrontation i mentioned earlier
between mirabel and her mother julieta
the cut scene takes place after a
devastated mirabelle has fled the
encounter filled with guilt and regret
for how she believes she's to blame for
the state of the family and alma decides
to go in search of her abuela sets out
on her own promising that when she
returns and julieta has healed they will
repair the family stronger than ever
after abuela arrives in her former
hometown she discovers a mural dedicated
to her beloved pedro with the words to
love us all is to love entirely and a
painting of him in the river with his
arms held up which honors the sacrifice
he made for the rest of the town when he
confronted the group of soldiers about
to attack them abuela wells up with
emotion at the memory of pedro and
remains at the mural overnight until the
following day a child tells her where
mirabelle is and in the alternate ending
abuela also confesses how after pedro's
death she held on too tight to her
family afraid to lose them again after i
lost him
i was so afraid i couldn't bear the
thought of losing anyone else and i
realize now
that my husband would be
so disappointed
because of all the people he would have
wished to understand his words it was me
and i am
so sorry a touch of this did make it
into the final film i was given a
miracle a second chance and i was so
afraid to lose it till i lost sight of
who or miracle was for and i am so sorry
there's also a fascinating alternate
reconciliation between mirabelle and
abuela hinted at in this concept art
where alma's hair transformed into a
river that ran for miles and mirabelle
had to find and follow the path of the
river in order to reach her grandmother
the idea here was to explore abuela's
ptsd following her husband's death and i
think the fantastically long river would
have been a metaphor for the depth of
alma's sorrow and how hard it was to
reach her emotionally the concept of
abuela's hair as a river fits nicely
with colombia's famous magical realism
which also inspired the rest of the
movie including the yellow butterflies
and magical rooms now if you'd love to
see even more deleted capybara moments
including them trash talking the maddie
girls be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell to get my next video
where i'll be talking about that and
more encounter deleted scenes i'll add a
link here and in the description as soon
as it's ready so what do you think of
these alternate endings and what would
you like to see happen in a future
encounter sequel or series let me know
in the comments below next tap left to
discover everything you missed at
encanto and if you enjoyed this video
then do leave a thumbs up i really
appreciate it thanks for enjoying this
movie with me and hope you have a
marvellous movie loving week yippie kai
movie lovers